new protests are expected tonight in the
former soviet republic of belarus
tens of thousands of people defied a
government crackdown
only yesterday calling for the country's
longtime ruler
to step down after an election widely
seen as a fraud
chris livesay is in the capital minsk
and
filed this report from yesterday's
protest
military in the streets
challenging peaceful protesters in a
former soviet republic
cold war imagery that's defining belarus
in 2020
this amateur video purportedly capturing
the moment undercover police officers
making arrests are
beaten back by protesters
new elections after alexandre lukashenko
the president of 26 years
stole them earlier this month
but he still got a birthday call from an
old ally russian president vladimir
putin
his present russian reserve forces ready
to deploy to belarus
at a time when putin is losing
popularity at home
and likely doesn't want russians getting
any inspiration from next door
where scenes and sentiments recall the
collapse of the soviet union
a bygone era when the white house
delivered fiery speeches
mr gorbachev tear down
this wall something these protesters
have yet to see for cbs this morning
chris livesay minsk
belarus